the xbox summer showcase has a date
microsoft is getting even closer to
buying activision blizzard and modern
warfare 2 has a logo
e3 2022 is not happening this year but
microsoft and bethesda are going ahead
with their own summer showcase the xbox
and bethesda game showcase will take
place on sunday june 12th at 10 a.m
pacific time 1pm eastern microsoft did
not provide any specifics regarding
games on display at the event but
bethesda's star field is a safe bet it
launches on november 11 2022 and could
be one of this year's biggest games
other than eldon ring of course
microsoft also has a new fable and forza
motorsport game in the works and that
could be shown off as well as for
bethesda the showcase could bring more
news about red fall and the indiana
jones game for machine games xbox boss
phil spencer teased the event saying
he's having a fun time visiting studios
and reviewing demos announcements and
scripts for the showcase he added quote
i feel like a fan who has sneaked behind
the stage watching the show get created
the announcement of the showcase comes
nearly a month after the esa cancelled
e3 which is now expected to return to la
in 2023 jeff keeley's annual summer
games fest is coming back this year
though there's no details yet regarding
the specifics of the show and in other
news activision blizzard shareholders
today voted on whether or not to approve
the proposed acquisition of the company
by microsoft and they overwhelmingly
approved the deal the publisher
announced that over 98
voted in favor of the deal paving the
way for the acquisition to go through
although there are still a number of
hurdles to overcome before it's a
reality the deal will still face
scrutiny from regulators including the
us's federal trade commission and those
in other regions including the eu and
china those could slow the deal or halt
it entirely should the deal go through
microsoft would become the world's third
biggest video game company following
tencent and sony it would put franchises
like call of duty warcraft and candy
crush under its control and no doubt
lead to an influx of games for xbox game
pass though just how it would handle
exclusivity for those series remains to
be seen back in january xbox boss phil
spencer tweeted about call of duty's
future on non-xbox platforms and said
quote had good calls this week with
leaders at sony i confirmed our intent
to honor all existing agreements upon
acquisition of activision blizzard and
our desire to keep call of duty on
playstation sony is an important part of
our industry and we value our
relationship and while we're on the
subject of cod the official logo for
call of duty modern warfare 2 has been
revealed while activision is teasing
that the game will usher in a new era
for call of duty an animation of the
logo appears to include some indistinct
chatter along with lines on what looks
like a topographical map both the audio
and other assets probably contain clues
about the game activision announced
modern warfare 2 earlier this year and
just this week the company said it will
be the most advanced entry in the series
to date now hit the comment section and
name this game but wrong answers only
the best one will get pinned i'll see
you tomorrow
you